هل ابنه زعيم كوريا الشماليه وريثته
القادمه لعرش بيون جانج فقد لوحظ ان كيم
جون جون كثف من ظهور ابنته كيم جو اي
للعالم على الرغم من ندره المعلومات حول
الفتاه يعتقد انها تبلغ من العمر 11 عاما
كيم جوي اي هي ثاني مولود لزعيم كوريا
الشماليه والتي خطفت الاضواء بالصوره
الدعائيه الاخيره وفي وقت سابق من فبراير
شوهدت تجلس جنبا الى جنب مع والدها في عرض
عسكري مكان لا يجلس فيه اي شخص بلا منصب
او مكانه رفيعه وفي الاسبوع الماضي تم نشر
صور لها وهي تحضر مادبه رسميه الى جانب
الجنرالات المزينين بالميداليات كما تم
تصوير ابنه الزعيم الصبيه كيم جوي اوي
مؤخرا وهي تصفق للاعبين في احدى مباراه
كره القدم في عطله وطنيه وهكذا قويه
التكهنات بان كيم جون جون ربما يعد ابنته
لتاخذ مكانه في حدث سيكون غير مسبوق في
تاريخ كوريا الشماليه فالبلاد لم تشهد
قاعده امراه من قبل
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي ابدى استعداده لوضع
النساء في مناصب في السلطه وقد عين كيم
بالفعل نساء في المناصب الابرز في نظامه
مثل شقيقته كيم يو جونغواي التي كان لها
ظهور قوي في فتره سابقه والتي مثلت كوريا
الشماليه على الساحه العالميه في دوره
الالعاب الاولمبيه الشتويه كما ان تشوي
تشغل منصبه وزير خارجيه كوريا الشماليه
[موسيقى]